- Since extending Taco
Tuesdays to Wednesday
we have seen a 13% increase in followers.
- I see.
- And we have some really
great promotions for August.
- About August, we were
thinking this might
be a good time to go with a new agency.
- Really?
- Unless you've got something
else that you can show me.
- No. I mean, it seems
like your mind is made up.
- Alright then. Bye.
(distant phone ringing)
- So should I stop working
on Taco Shark Week?
- They were our oldest client.
How do you do it Elliott?
- Do what?
- Fail.
- Fail?
- You walk around with
your pants unbuttoned.
You can't get a fortune out of a cookie
so you eat the whole thing.
No one can remember your dumb name.
- Well I'm working on a new
nickname, E Dog or L Train.
- And all your boss
can do is lose clients.
- It'll be okay.
- What are you doing?
- I thought you needed a hug.
- I don't like to be touched.
- Oh yeah, I forgot, I'm sorry.
I'll just go.
- Maybe I should just go.
- Hey why didn't you fight for it?
We had great ideas.
- I know but I got nervous.
- The only time I'm not
nervous is the moment I wake up
and I'm trying to figure
out if it's real life
or a waking nightmare.
- Actual confrontation is
a little different Elliott.
- But you're the boss,
this is what you do.
- What do you know?
You let people walk all over you.
- But I'm not the boss
here, I am the boss at home.
- You live alone.
- Well, Mr. Harris and Britney
Purrs are my employees.
- No, they're your cats.
- My incredibly well
behaved cats, who can use
a toilet because I insisted on it.
I got an idea, come with old L Train.
(plucky guitar music)
- Summer, can you get some coffee?
- I'm super busy right
now, but how about later?
- Okay, goodbye.
- That's it?
You're the boss, this is your house, go.
- Summer, I need you to get
me and Elliott some coffee.
- Oh, sure thing boss.
(plucky guitar music)
- See isn't this great?
- It's incredible, I asked
for something and I got it.
- Now for something a
little more challenging.
- Bennett, get up.
(moans)
It's 4pm you have to go back to work.
- Five minutes.
- No, right now because we do not
have siestas in this office.
I don't care how many semesters
you spent in Barcelona.
- It's pronounced Barthelona.
- You're unbearable.
Drink this and go back to your cube.
- Fine.
- Thank you.
- I'm doing it, I'm being the boss.
- Like a cat who can use a
toilet, you are unstoppable.
- You're right Elliott.
I want you to make a dating profile.
- What?
No this isn't about me, this is about you
becoming the person you were meant to be.
- No I think this is about you expanding
your horizons beyond cats
who shit like people.
- I don't have any good photos
or favorite movie, or cool Ghandi quotes.
- Hold still.
- Okay, no no no.
Here, I'll do it if you
call back Viva Taquito.
- Mr. Taquito, this is Natalie.
Your company needs to
connect with local teens.
We are the only social
media company in the area
that can get the job done right.
With our guidance we can push
Taco Tuesday straight through to Saturday,
and God willing, maybe
even Sunday, excellent.
(claps)
- So what did he say?
- I got the machine.
- You did it.
- I still don't like
being touched Elliott.
- Oh yeah, sorry, forgot.
- I hate it here, when I
turn 18 I'm moving out.
(laughter)
(orchestra warm up)
(film projector)
(dial up modem)